foreign
back again for the iron Lords podcast at
lordsofgaming.net back again and PAX
East 2023 we're here at the Yacht Club
games booth and I'm here with Celia
Schilling the director of marketing for
uh Yacht Club games High School
excited to share with you our game okay
so what is the first game what is the
second thing we're going to talk about
now double knife dig well first off
Shovel Knight dig is the prequel to The
Original shovel of posts like game that
started the entire show tonight series
um Shovel Knight dig is a roguelike
adventure it takes you through
technically procedure generated slash on
handcrafted levels it's a mix of both
fun things and I feel like you'll really
enjoy it so it's a roguelike clockwise
restart I'm so sorry I messed up so much
this one okay
Shovel Knight dig is
that the original Shovel Knight game
that started the whole franchise and it
can't be for you to hop in
absolutely let's take a look at it yes
I'm good
Okay so
so into it so we developed this game
alongside Nitro
um and basically have game starts off
you know you play a Shovel Knight and
usual on someone interrupts his peaceful
campsite you have to go on adventure
this time around it's drill night
and actually
absolutely newer demo so we're gonna
explore this together so let's explore
at the secret fountain
a spoiler alert uh you will encounter
from
uh in this case so the one that you face
in this level is actually more right
since this is a pretty cool
um you
learn a little bit more about the
characters
in trouble
[Music]
the type of thing where it's going to be
it's pretty much opening brand new areas
as we go down or is everything sort of
you said
generation uh so so everything kind of
happens on the fly would you be able to
sort of dig indefinitely okay so foreign
levels so they're all stitched together
um so it's like a every time you play
something new is going to happen which
is great for gameplay really hard when
I'm trying to make a trailer so for it
um How does it go down to each level um
you have to go through three stages
so you know it follows that path but
each time you go down it's different as
you play the game you actually you'll
get to choose which app you go at the
bottom of the level so sometimes like
after you beat masterminds that's the
first level you can choose between
Tinker night's level and you can choose
the secret fountain
the one sort of options in terms of
where you go depending on your gameplay
but to get the true ending uh
girl yeah that's why I absolutely want
to be I love roguelike games so it is
the type of thing where I just jump in
and I really do want to see everything
that it has to offer oh yeah but again
playing comparing it a little bit to
something like a steam world dig that
kind of just lets you go off
indefinitely and again for a lot of
people that's cool but at the same time
something that's created in sort of
bespoke is also something that that's
very interesting so I really am excited
to see what you guys are building
to even expand on the adventure so on
March 17
th so after you beat the game um in
order to buy Black Knight A Familiar you
get into shovel Knights game or whatever
um and basically uh Black Knight
discovers that there's something came
that's going on the world besides all
the other stuff going on so it's up to
you two to investigate so what's cool
about it is that um
it basically expands the adventure even
more and there's uh some really
interesting challenges that do make it
seem like it keeps on color so I think
that you would definitely enjoy that as
well oh and by the way
um the DLC is out now on Apple arcade
and on scene coming soon excellent he
just took the words right around I was
going to ask you when it's coming okay
I said Thank You Celia so much this is
Lord Sovereign here for the iron Lords
podcast with lordsofgaming.net here at
the Yacht Club games Booth we
Supple Knight dig face